a story we brought you just a moment ago
Fox News Alert the White House medical
team confirming that a valet to
President Trump has confirmed positive
for the corona virus the White House
just put out a statement Hogan did Lee
saying that the President and Vice
President had both since been tested and
were negative for the virus and in good
health chief White House correspondent
John Roberts is reporting that for us
and he joins us now live this morning
hey John Sandra good morning to you yeah
this was a member of the military the
Navy who works here on the White House
grounds as one of the president's valets
they take care of the president's
wardrobe they could also perform other
services for the president typically
they do have from time to time during
the day close contact with the president
we're told that this service member was
not feeling well yesterday was tested
and tested positive for coronavirus we
do not know what sort of proximity this
person has been in to the president in
the last few days it is significant
though that the president and the vice
president have tested been tested and
tested negative particularly since the
vice president is at a nursing home in
Alexandria Virginia today though he is
not going inside the building it's not
the first time that the president has
been in proximity to somebody who has
tested positive for corona virus to
remember back at the beginning of March
and March the 7th when Brazilian
President hier bolson ro and his
entourage came to mar-a-lago Bal Sedaris
communications person came down with
coronavirus there are also rumors that
bolson aro did but those proved not to
be correct and then in the middle of
March a member of the vice president's
staff tested positive for corona virus
so as far as I know this is just the
second case among personnel at the White
House we'll continue to ask questions
about how close this person may have
come to the president but thus far we
know both the President and the Vice
President are testing negative they've
got those Abbott lab tests here at the
White House they can get results back in
a couple of hours the White House is
also conducting serological testing for
any staff member who wants to know if
they were exposed previously to the
corona virus
so you know there's there's a lot of
surveillance going on here in terms of
the virus and its prevalence but as far
as we know this is only the second
positive test of any member of the or at
least any of the people who work here on
the campus all right John Roberts on
that breaking news for us this morning
John thank you